new york dont les habitants auront sans
doute écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
les révélations entre guillemets de
celui qu'on présente comme le cerveau
des attentats du 11 septembre khaled
cheikh mohammed
numéro 3 d'al qaïda a été interrogé pour
la première fois à guantanamo il
revendique l'attentât mais aussi une
trentaine d'autres détails également
certains projets d'assassinât contre
bill clinton et jimmy carter des aveux
qui suscitent le doute
christelle bertrand aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas de quoi il a l'air cette photo
de khaled cheikh mohammed a été prise
lors de son arrestation en 2003 depuis
il est tenu au secret par les américains
dans des aveux rendue publique par le
pentagone il déclare être responsable
des attentats du 11-septembre de art à z
khaled cheikh mohammed ne s'arrête pas
là il décrit comme en février 2002 il a
lui même décapité daniel pearl
le journaliste américain enlevé au
pakistan l'ex numéro trois du réseau al
qaïda chef des opérations militaires
revendique aussi l'attentât à la bombe
dans une discothèque de bali où 200
personnes sont tuées en tout khaled
cheikh mohammed reconnaît avoir signé 30
et une opération terroriste
il avouait tout cela à guantanamo la
prison militaire américaine sur l'île de
cuba
il y est détenu depuis septembre dernier
toutes les informations de cette
première audition ne sont livrés que par
l'armée américaine
aucun avocat aucun témoin civile n'a
assisté à ces aveux l'homme aux
multiples visages affirme avoir voulu
assassiner bill clinton jimmy carter et
jean paul ii
khaled cheikh mohammed et comme
l'appellent les américains
un prisonnier de haute valeur qui
pourrait bientôt être traduits devant un
tribunal militaire d'exception
en bref on